good morning Johnny this Monday May 17th
which is apparently a very important day
because it is YouTube's fifth birthday
which no it's not
YouTube was created in February of 2005
but I guess they're marking May 17th as
the birth of the YouTube community I
don't know what happened on May 17th but
apparently something good I would like
to know it appears to mean that nothing
of significance to YouTube happened on
May 17 2005 and so that is my first
problem with them choosing this
particular date as the birthday of the
YouTube community the second problem
that I have is that today is already
very important birthday and they can't
have this woman because today is the
birthday of the most important Catherine
in the entire world
please leave your birthday wishes for
the Catherine in the comments see
YouTube is celebrating this fifth
anniversary of the YouTube community by
asking people to submit their YouTube
stories and I watched few of these are
actually really interesting and good you
should check them out there is also a
very cool timeline of the history of the
YouTube community and I would like to
point out that there is only one person
who did not found YouTube who was on
that timeline twice and it's it's me I
don't know if you know this but I'm kind
of a big deal
interestingly there's another green
brother who was not on the timeline it
at all but to be frank the reason that
I'm on the timeline has very little to
do with me one of the videos featured on
the timeline is Alan my business partner
and I announcing and discussing dftba
records the record company that
represents solely YouTube musicians and
the other one is Katherine and I sitting
on a thrift store couch that I forgot
that I had ever owned in our old house
singing a song about how amazing the
first project for awesome was and of
course the project for awesome has
gotten bigger and better since then but
I'm very flattered and very glad that
YouTube decided to feature those videos
as a substantial part of the YouTube
community but John I am much more proud
and much more flattered that people
chose to work with us on those projects
because without those people they would
be nothing so of course everyone has
their own YouTube story but the real
story of YouTube the interesting one
anyway is about groups of people who get
together and do things and have fun
together even though they very rarely
occupy the same physical space so that's
my youtube story my brother convinced me
to do something ridiculous that we
thought was going to be about two people
but turned out to be about a lot more
than that now I must go and make my wife
special day special John I'll see you on
Wednesday